[Aplausos]
muy buenas noches cómo están
que se escuche más fuerte como están es
un gusto para mí estar con ustedes en
este escenario la verdad es que nunca
pensé que me pudiera poner tan nervioso
por estar en un punto rojo es como ya
presentaron hace un momento yo soy diego
centeno tengo 29 años de edad de los
cuales 14 los he dedicado plenamente a
la magia y el ilusionismo
por eso me conocen como el mago cripto
desde muy pequeño
disfruto de esto de la magia y de hacer
trucos y gracias al apoyo de mis padres
me enrolé en este medio en el medio de
la magia de los payasos y demás y ahí me
di cuenta que desafortunadamente el mago
es víctima de un estereotipo es
inevitable pensar en un mago y no pensar
en el sombrero de copa
la varita la capa la caja llena de
estrellas y el niño parado frente a sus
primos haciendo magia
una paloma cosas por el estilo es
inevitable también me di cuenta que la
magia sufre de lo mismo que muchas artes
falta de espacios falta de lugares falta
de cultura falta de interés y también
requiere lo mismo que muchas artes
pasión emoción autoconocimiento estudio
práctica y sobre todo un público que
esté dispuesto a verlo y disfrutarlo
cuando me metí en este medio
desafortunadamente descubrí que el
estereotipo del mago mexicano en la
mayoría de los casos era real tal vez no
el sombrero de copa y la varita pero si
la falta de preparación mágica la falta
de interés por parte de los magos por
buscar algo más y por supuesto la ssa de
cannes con vestido chiquito y poca ropa
pero también aprendí que hay otro grupo
de magos que se tomaban en serio esto
con ellos aprendí que existen libros
profesionales de magia dvds
profesionales de magia reuniones clubes
congresos donde tú puedes aprender y
profundizar a lo que estás haciendo y
ahí me cuenta me di cuenta de algo que
la magia no era un arte
la magia en un medio por el cual yo
podía expresarme
era la pintura con lo que ella con la
que yo iba a plasmar mi idea y puse
manos a la obra me tome más en serio lo
que estaba haciendo empecé a asistir a
estos congresos a estas reuniones a
estos clubes
y descubrí algo muy interesante esto me
llevó primero a estar como ustedes entre
el público aprendiendo tomando notas
viendo que podía yo absorber de ese mago
que estaba en el escenario después pude
estar yo en el escenario compartiendo
mis ideas dando conferencias no solo
para magos sino para diferentes grupos
de personas que les interesaba la magia
esto me llevó a ganar diversos premios a
nivel nacional 5 primeros lugares a
nivel nacional después a trabajar para
grandes empresas como nissan cocacola
royal caribbean international chevrolet
etcétera más recientemente como profesor
en el tecnológico de monterrey y todo
eso siendo mago
ay me di cuenta de algo
que si existe el interés por la magia en
méjico que si había gente que quería ver
un espectáculo que se había gente que
esperaba el siguiente show que llegase a
su ciudad
el siguiente mago que llegase al
restaurante y les mostrara algo
diferente que les dio una experiencia
mágica entonces sí sí existe la gente
que quiere ver magia o que no hay
cultura mágica en mexico
y tuve que ser muy frío en esta
respuesta
porque no hay suficientes magos
dispuestos a utilizar la magia como un
medio no hay suficientes magos
dispuestos a desarrollarse como artistas
para después tomar la magia y expresarse
con ella y esto no aplica sólo para la
magia ya explica aplica para cualquier
arte en un problema propio no un
problema de la sociedad así que puse
manos a la obra a partir de ese momento
me puso una meta personal tenía que
presentar por lo menos tres espectáculos
al año por lo menos yo solo en cualquier
lugar en cualquier condición en
cualquier espacio después me reuní con
dos amigos más y formamos un grupo que
se llama hagamos magia y decidimos hacer
tres espectáculos y por supuesto comencé
a apoyar a mis compañeros para que ellos
también presentarán sus espectáculos
asistiendo o a veces participando oa
veces simplemente publicando en mis
redes sociales pero no era suficiente el
mayor problema era que hacíamos magia
literalmente en cualquier lugar bares
restaurantes antros centros nocturnos
cualquier espacio que lo permitiera lo
hacíamos
cuál era el problema la logística
iluminación falta falta de lugares a
veces tenemos que rentar sillas y
ponerlas nosotros quitar las mesas
teníamos que ajustar el espectáculo al
lugar y esto nos rompía con el
estereotipo del mago seguíamos
ofreciendo el mismo espectáculo porque
yo no me podía expresar expresar en ese
lugar y en ese momento
en una ocasión me dice mi novia hoy
llevaba ni el cirque du soleil de
guadalajara vamos yo nunca había ido se
aclaró máximo sabe la genial sabía que
era genial pero pues nunca había
asistido compramos los boletos y pues
fuimos no
me voló la cabeza desde meses antes la
gente se peleaba por comprar los boletos
por conseguirlos ya estando dentro del
lugar de esta carpa increíble las luces
el escenario
todo el espectáculo era increíble todo
estaba pensado y diseñado para que los
espectadores únicamente se preocuparan
por ver el show por disfrutarlo pero lo
que más llamó mi atención fue el
escenario el escenario estaba pensado
para dos cosas primero estaba pensado
para que cualquier artista que se
subiese en ese escenario lo único de lo
que se tenía que preocupar en ese
instante era de dar lo mejor de sí
cualquier artista que pisaba ese
escenario tenía que estar al nivel para
poder estar ahí
con ese bien mente recibe una llamada
dos meses después un amigo que había
tenido un bar y con el que en algún
momento había trabajado me dice oye
cripto tengo un café y quiero hacer
shows de magia una vez al mes el lugar
pequeñito 4x4 no cabían más de 20
personas hice la reunión con él
planteamos todo y lo hicimos al mes
hicimos el primer espectáculo de magia
en ese lugar un fiasco
llegaron únicamente seis personas entre
ellos las personas de barra el mesero mi
amigo el gerente y dos amigos
no sé quién más porque compró el boleto
pero fue hicimos el show con una mesa de
plástico plegable y un cuadro de tela
rojo que me encantaría tener esa foto
que nunca entendí porque simplemente lo
pegaron en la pared
pero no nos desanimamos dijimos bueno
fue nuestro primer intento no ya no era
suficiente nos volvimos a reunir y le
dije amigo johnny elige jon y ya no
podemos ser lo mismo estamos mejorar la
experiencia así que empecé a trabajar
montamos en la parte de atrás un pequeño
telón para que pareciera que estuvieses
frente al escenario la mesa ya no era
una mesa plegable una mesa más especial
más preocupaban preocupando más por los
detalles compré una cámara como una
pantalla para que toda la gente pudiera
ver compramos iluminación para que todo
luciera mucho mejor y volvimos a ser el
siguiente show llegaron 30 personas
llenamos
fue increíble recuerdo que estaba mi
amiga fotógrafa disparando en todos
lados me enseñaba las fotos y agua
increíble me encantaba lo que parecía lo
que hacíamos al mes siguiente con el
mismo ánimo hicimos otro show y lo
volvimos a llenar funcionó funcionó
estaba estaba está muy bien hecho viene
el tercer mes y recibe una llamada
cripto vamos a cerrar el café
tienes que venir por tus cosas lo antes
posible nos están pidiendo el local
y por las cosas la subí a mi carro
llega a mi casa y dije y ahora qué
fuiste emocionado y esa flama estaba
encendida dentro de mí y nadie me iba a
detener
hablé con otro amigo que tenía un barco
en el cual ya habíamos hecho una
temporada el año anterior el año
anterior e hicimos cuatro shows hablé
con él dije le platiqué toda la
problemática todo lo que había aprendido
que ya no quería estar moviendo las
sillas y las mesas y demás así que fui
más directo ya sabía lo que quería le
dije yo ni perdón
oscar necesito que me rent es un espacio
permanente dentro de tu bar para poder
hacer shows de magia
se me quedó viendo como un minuto
pensando y se ven sígueme fuimos al
segundo piso del bar y me presento su
bodega un cuadro de 6 x 6
lleno de botellas
papeles pasos cristalería un escritorio
viejo un librero enorme dos sillones me
dice te sirve
si me sirve adelante a la semana
siguiente habló con el padre con mi
hermano saben que conseguir lugar
acompáñenme a limpiarlo lo limpiamos lo
dejamos impecable se fueron todos
y yo me quedé parado a la mitad de ese
cuadro
y ahora qué
ya tengo el lugar ahora que era el
lienzo en blanco que necesitaba sin
saber qué iba a pasar agarré un cuaderno
y empecé a dibujar lo que en mi mente
era ese espacio empecé a dibujarlo a
diseñar y demás y me fui a mi casa
a la semana siguiente sin tener el menor
conocimiento de carpintería de
electricidad de equipos de sonido de
nada puse manos a la obra con tarimas de
estas que vamos a los supermercados de
madera alguna gradería para 20 personas
sin herramientas para cortar fui a la
carpintería que está cerca de mi casa
les pedí que lo cortaban no quedaba
tenía que volver a ir pasarme
compré las sillas compré equipo de
iluminación un poco más profesional
aprendí a instalarlas aprendí a
programar las aprendí cómo funciona
estuve durante horas picando botones
aprendiendo cómo funcionaba todo eso
compré un equipo de sonido no sabía cómo
funciona un equipo de sonido me puse a
trabajar en el equipo de sonido
instale un telón no sabía cómo instalar
un telón y me puse instalarlo busque en
internet cómo instalar un telón salen
que instalan tela en su casa yo soy la
persona adecuada soy experto en este
instante
en dos meses construir la galera mágica
el primer espacio pensado y creado para
la magia y el ilusionismo en mexico
donde el mes con mes presentamos por lo
menos dos espectáculos de magia para el
público tenemos un club de magia una
biblioteca mágica reuniones mensuales
para todos aquellos que quieren convivir
con la comunidad mágica de guadalajara
hemos recibido magos de tokio japon de
chicago de brasil y por supuesto de
mexico
presentamos un open magic el primer
micrófono abierto de magia en méjico
donde cualquier aspirante a mago puede
subirse a ese escenario y compartir con
un público real sus ideas lo que
próximamente será parte de su
espectáculo
ha sido una experiencia
increíble
única
ya puse manos a la obra
nada me puede detener y nadie me va a
frenar
y espero que todos aquellos que estén en
este espacio o fuera de él un día nos
acompañen y puedan tener una experiencia
verdaderamente mágica
[Aplausos]